j'ai vraiment hâte de les rencontrer
mais j'ai hâte pour à la flamme c'est la
possibilité de vivre une grande histoire
d'amour celle dont elle a toujours rêvé
marc désignera la personne qui quittera
l'aventuré ce soir
et c'est elle pour chantal et jesé
l'occasion d'une grosse éclate marquer
j'espère juste que tu aimes les femmes
comme moi j'aime la cire chaude pour
orchidées ça serait de l'amour c'est
tout simplement ça si tu aime
l'originalité avec moi tu vas être
servient pro au bac ce serait d'avoir le
regard de marque toute la journée sur m
je suis photographe professionnel ah bah
oui ça me surprend oui oui ça représente
bas de l'eau chaude de l'électricité à
volonté un toit ouais pas toi il ya même
la climat énergie oui c'est une radio
c'est le radeau c'est le radeau pour
elle est-ce que tu sentirait prêt à
fonder une famille oui je crois ou
novembre une nouvelle vie se faire
apprivoiser par les humains une
révélation un amour qu'elle n'a pas
encore connu si jésus qui m'a guidé vers
marqué jésus ne se trompe jamais sauf
pour judas rester dans l'aventuré à voir
la joie de rester avec des filles qui
potentiellement pourrait finir dans son
lit elles sont pas là encore les
méthodes suis assis chez son total en
tant qu est super cool